I'm Eve and you're my special friend
it's me Eve and I'm your special friend
we waited almost 20 years for this but
it did not disappoint
I have to ask though why is it not
called life-size to Christmas Eve you
don't like that no I'm really mad at you
right because it should be called that
there's time it doesn't premiere for a
few weeks so good it was just what I was
thinking the whole time all right
we're off to a weird start now let's
bring the energy back up yeah it's time
for you to go because I'm pretty sure
you're crazy
crazy girl when you kept telling us for
like the two years you're working on
this yeah you're gonna see a different
eve it's a different even you met
literally it's going to be a difference
Eve a different Eve comes to life yeah I
can't go back now and everything that
you taught me will be a part of all the
tops we do see the original Eve yeah
she's in that same outfit we left that
Eve is back in Sunnyvale and because she
did such a good job with Casey
she is promoted to like president of
headquarters so that was the president's
amazing bright beautiful office she's
president of Sunnyvale headquarters and
here many Eve's that had been sent to
earth she's dealing with this one right
now that just doesn't have the self
esteem and she's like get it together
because our lives and our existence
depend on you and she delivers an iconic
Tyra moment yeah I am rooting for you we
are all rooting for you how dare you
doubt yourself I felt that it was
necessary to be Metta I feel like there
are so many fans coming from America's
Next Top Model and just my general fans
and putting that Easter Egg in there I
just feel like the rooms of people
watching this in their living rooms or
on their phones wherever they're
watching there they go no she didn't
and yes we did hear your notes from your
Khalid Eve Eve
crane job secretary what would you do
without me
[Music]
there are a lot of knots the first film
well the nods were surgical I studied
the original movie over and over and
over and over again and was saying okay
we have to put these things in there but
not just the repeat of it what is the
next level for that so I thought I did a
great job that's liquid butter I love
her and then I get to set and she's like
you don't have this you don't have this
you don't have this in everything that
this big fan star of the movie asked for
I put in dad used to call up my hundred
watt smile
yes it got short-circuited what was the
number one request you had like this has
to make it in the movie okay dress me
okay what's your favorite Easter egg in
this one I want you to be my extra
special friend you don't want you to be
my extra special friend
that's also part of the different Eve
we're seeing an evening filled if er
enormocorp because the person that she
comes alive for it is a 25 year old
woman so she sees the world more through
those eyes as opposed through the eyes
of a little girl now Lindsay Lohan we
see photo of her which she's not in this
was she ever going to be a part of this
did we try to make that happen
oh yeah Lindsay was trying to make that
happen I mean she was up in my DM signed
up and her dams we were slide and left
and right for a while because I
definitely wanted her to have a cameo in
the movie but she has heard beach clubs
and big MTV show and she could not get
to Atlanta and so it was up to the last
minute of us trying to make it happen
and she couldn't she had a contractual
obligation
[Music]
I would be remiss not to try and end
this but we do it'll be a scar
sing-along yeah all right you have to
start us off first line go ahead
Yves great no matter where she goes
dress her up from her head to her toes
on the town at the mall he loves high
fashion after dark at the club keep it
up the whole night dancing shine bright
shine fire don't be shy be a star where
you live where you offer to be a star
Wow now answer attire I can't get better
than that you cannot and you get the
high note I tried I thought you're gonna
crack didn't know thanks guys
[Music]